[Music]
the goal is not to be successful and
famous that's not the goal the goal is
if you have a specific god-given ability
to live your life out through that one
and two we have a responsibility to push
the conversation forward until we're all
equal on this place because until
everyone's free no one's free and that's
just right that's just the fact
we are all linked some kind of way so if
you oppress a certain people everyone's
in danger we're basically the same once
you take away who we are take away where
we come from you know we pretty much
have the same things you know you ask a
person who they love the first thing
they'll probably say is their mother
their husband or whomever I mean we all
love the same thing we all want the same
thing we all have the same fears you
know fear failure we all have the same
aspirations to treat people as they are
no matter who they are no matter where
they sit in the world not to like be
super nice to someone who added to high
position or a mean to someone who they
deem to be below them I can't buy you
love I can't show it to you I can show
you affection and I can express love but
I can't put it in your hand right I
can't put compassion in your hand I
can't show you that right so the most
beautiful things are things that are
visible that's what the important things
lie fairness and compassion and like
empathy and a loving heart and those
things translate in any environment
those are the main base things that you
want I grew so much from the experience
but I think the most important thing I
got is that everything is connected
every emotion is connected and comes
from somewhere and just being aware of
it being aware of it everyday life puts
you at such a
you is such an advantage you know you
realize that someone's racist toy you're
not even about you it ain't about you
it's about their upbringing and what
happened to them and how they make LED
them to this point you know most bullies
bully these young men coming from these
they're just in pain you have to survive
so you're going to survival mode when
you're going to survival one what
happened shut down right you shut down
all the Motions so even with women
you've got shut down emotionally so you
can't connect
and then all things happen from there
I've been taught everything but
emotional intelligence you know that's
not what you thought as a Young Man
growing up in projects you taught to
survive the strongest thing a man can do
is cry to expose your feelings to be
vulnerable in front of the world that's
real strength you know you feel like you
got to be this guarded person that's not
real
fake a lot of people have never been in
it our little world was all we knew we
didn't know anything outside of that
world so to look and see people that
look like you achieving great things
it's like oh there is more you know
improve self-esteem and it proves
improves on upon self-worth you know
because a lot of choices are made are
made from the position of you know my
life is not worth much and I'm not this
sort of living is not much so if I risk
my life you know what am I really
missing but if you know you know how
valuable human life is you'll have more
respect for yours and fathers these
things are going to affect real life
people when you put in like prison
reform like people are going to jail and
families are being broke up and fathers
away from their children and the family
structure is broken so that kid grows up
that kid gets into trouble he goes to
jail and the cycle is vicious when you
look at those situations I had a similar
situation with my pop not being around
as well you know what crack the code for
me was like what was he going through
he's doing this to me and when I looked
at it from his position like my dad
wasn't around and you know all these
things happened and then when I took a
further look things happen and you are a
result of those things so you feel you
feel that boy that's not around this
would have been told for you to been
able to take me to a baseball game and
all these things and then life on top of
that like he can't get a job you know
the guy at the office is cursing them
out making them feel less than a man but
he gotta take it cause he needed 6.50 an
hour so life beating him down so he
comes home he's defeated he don't you
know he's supposed to pick you up on
Saturday he's exhausted so you we don't
we don't Factor those things in we don't
look at things through those lenses yeah
seeing things from other people's
perspective and what other people are
going through you have to educate your
children on the world as it exists today
and how it got to that space But my
child doesn't need the same tools that I
needed growing up I needed certain tools
to survive my area and my child as me
being grown up in a different
environment but also they have to know
their history have a sense of what it
took to get to this place and have
compassion for others to I identify with
everyone's struggle and to
no these people made these sacrifices
for us to to be where we are and to push
that forward for us sometimes you place
in situations of hopelessness in your
places situations where you have no
other way out but what people would deem
wrong what you're doing it with good
intelligence just do things that are
true to you most things that I'm
involved with are extension of being
creative and also have a standard for
yourself and have some sort of integrity
and try to find some sort of Truth in
what you're doing I think every move
made like we're going to compare to
chess I think every move made is to be
learned from whether it was a good or a
bad move
and I think it all sets your you set you
on a path so in order for me to take
back any of those moves I would I would
have to be unhappy with where I am now
and where I am now is I couldn't even
imagine in my wildest dreams that I
would be here
so for me to take any of those moves
back will be affecting the natural
course of where I am now I wouldn't
rather I wouldn't want to be anywhere
else cause there are things in life that
you say I could have done differently
but knowing that and being aware of that
for me it's helped me every chest move
that I made I was like ah he's gonna do
that it was followed up but because I
know from that one okay now I have to
change my strategy because you know I
moved that there he's going to move
there now I have to move this over here
you know so at the end of the game I
trapped the queen in the corner I have
the king in my side so I'm pretty I'm
pretty happy with who I am my
responsibility is to the culture you
know my my job is to show it in a great
light so I guess I'm a role model in
that way but as far as the way I live my
life I'm a human being in the beginning
it's about you and your circle okay
right you take your circle you got the
people that grind with you every day and
share your dreams and slept on the floor
with you and then you make it out and
then you look and he's okay what else
how else can I be of service you know
and as and as you move further and
further away from you achieve these
goals that you thought were you know
unattainable in the beginning and you
achieve them and then you look around
and you say okay
how can we duplicate this you know when
you have someone behind you that really
believe in what's right
it motivates you to do the right thing
you get to to
um a point in your life and you like
really focus on what's important
you know what I'm saying is that we
can't afford any mistakes at this point
and so you're just really focus on
what's important to you and people you
love and that that's what really just
brings me genuine happiness you know
just hanging out you know all my friends
came I'm pointing that way because then
all my friends have the most beautiful
things are not these objects the most
beautiful things are inside the most
beautiful things are the friendships I
have are really like gold and
friendships that you know most people
don't have you can have all the watches
and paintings in the world you don't
have a friend like it's friends like I
had the friendships I've Acquired and
the compassion and the person I've
become like that's that's what this
chapter is I always believed in
um the way you live your life you affect
the outcome of your life you can't
control the future I mean you could
control it up to some point you can't
control what others do you can't control
anything things don't happen to you they
happen for you that's life